hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today demon slayer just
demon saya
so I've recently watched episode 19 and
I don't know what this video is it's not
like a review or any kind of analysis
it's more of a stream of consciousness
and yes I know I'm very late to this
party but I also don't really care now a
whole ton of you commented on episode 19
in my first impressions video hoping
that I would make it that far and
telling me that it would somewhat blow
my mind and you guys weren't exactly
wrong which is particularly impressive
because after all of the comments I went
into episode nineteen expecting
something pretty big to happen and what
I saw still very much exceeded my
expectations and look initially what I
wanted to do was time to this video
something like the greatest fight in
anime history you know something nice
and clickbait tea but also arguably true
because that sort of thing is almost
entirely subjective anyway however when
I took a step back I realized such title
would be doing episode 19 and grave
injustice because it's not just about
the fight because this entire episode
was just beautifully constructed
allowing that one particular moment to
shine and the key thing that allows
everything to work is one word that word
being family having come this far into
the series I'd begun to realize that
part of the charm Demon Slayer presents
is through this concept because it's
actually very rarely explored in a
shounen series many of which featured a
young male protagonist with no familial
ties presumably to make their call to
adventure much easier to accept and to
not have too many realistic
complications bulking down an
action-adventure story but what many
writers would see as a narrative
restriction demon slayer chooses to put
great emphasis on and in my opinion is a
core factor that has allowed episode 19
to transcend itself because here's the
thing on paper this episode should have
infuriated me and that's because our
young and still relatively inexperienced
protagonist managed to get the better of
one of the twelve Kazuki out of demon
moons whatever you prefer
but in any case they are a group that
have been built up thus far to be second
only to Michael Jackson demon himself
there is nothing that should have
allowed tandro to overcome such a beast
at his current level and anything that
did would be poor portion and
storytelling at least that's what I
would have thought before seeing this
episode in fact during the entire thing
I was expecting you to show up and save
tandro and that only actually stopped
when tandra engaged in his he no kami
thing go and that's when I went no he's
not actually
going to beat him is he that would be
one of the biggest ass pulls in anime
history surely of course at the time I
really didn't care if that was going to
be the case because my god this anime is
just so stunning the fire animation is
every bit as mesmerizing as the water I
love so much and they've done a
fantastic job of making it feel more
volatile and just plain more powerful
which allows me to accept what's
happening even if my brain doesn't feel
quite right about it but once again on
paper this is a simple powerup
it's a classic Shonen protagonist comes
up against an insurmountable power and
has to rapidly evolve during battle to
overcome it except that it isn't because
there's another complication that it's
not just one powerup it's two because
the other part of this equation that my
mind had all but forgotten until now was
Nezzer ku thus far she spent the series
being tones Rose driving force and
somewhat relevant to combat but nothing
approaching what happens here when she
activates her blood demon art after that
happened I felt entirely satisfied
there's just something so wonderful in
gaining power through familial bonds
because tandra achieved this assumedly
through their father austere Zuko is
awakened by their mother and then it's
like the bonds of a whole family coming
together to overcome ruie which is just
such poetic justice as well because rui
has spent his demonic career trying to
mimic these bonds only to be beaten by
the very thing that he seeks and at this
time I should also point out that the
anime doesn't deserve complete credit
for this because it was assumedly all
faithfully adapted from the manga where
these wonderful ideas were laid out
however the way it was portrayed in
motion to me epitomizes my love for this
medium and the absurd amount of
potential it has to elevate an already
stunning story when implemented
correctly and I may still be on a high
from just having watched it recently but
I would legitimately call the final two
minutes of episode 19 one of my favorite
anime moments of all time everything
about it is perfect from the motion of
the movement which slides skillfully
between spectacularly fast and
spellbinding ly slow and you know what
it almost comes across as a perfectly
choreographed dance with the music and
the music my god here's another thing
that out of context I never would have
thought would work so well if you'd
played me that song and told me look
this is what we're going to use for the
most climactic battle of the series so
far and I would have severely questioned
your sanity however in this context it
works so damn well because it's more
subdued and emotionally focused nature
only goes to serve the idea of family
and add that intimate energy which is
very much needed to make this moment
100% convincing plus what the song lacks
in
if you're on fizz more than made up for
with the sound effects of the action on
screen which more often than not
followed their own musical nature so
there's this incredible juxtaposition of
soft warmth with desperate action that
really should not work anywhere near as
well as it does but of course my
favorite moment is the impact this is a
masterclass of how object should collide
in anime both the force and resistance
look perfect the sound is glorious and
the particle animation really sells the
sheer power emanating from the strike
making it all the more believable when a
Zuko's blood demon art goes off again
and results in the decapitation and you
know then of course there's this moment
of beauty in all of my many many years I
have never seen a more stunning
decapitation and after this I had to
immediately go to the manga I needed to
know exactly how much of this action was
mandated by what was on the page and
what the anime had taken into its own
hands to elevate and the answer is after
seeing episode 19 I was honestly
disappointed with what I saw in what I
think was chapter 40 of the manga and
you might be saying that it's probably
really not fair to compare the manga to
any anime adaptation but there are
certainly series out there whose manga
greatly outshines its anime counterpart
from what I've seen I don't think this
is one of those circumstances but you
know what it's not fair to judge the
manga based solely on the comparison
with this godlike anime scene and having
gotten this far into the series I do
plan on reading the manga once the anime
has concluded still this episode is
without a doubt a crowning achievement
of 2019 and full credit to you photo
ball for crafting this masterwork and
that pretty much does it for whatever
this was if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produced in
general and please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
area takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on demon slayer episode 19 this
has been the new old review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]